the head a has as you notice some quick
marks in this is my this is our
introduction to inverse functions now
the reason why I put introduction in
inverted commas is because even though
this we're starting off a new topic for
AIDS is going to be great you've
actually been using inverse function
inverse functions for years good morning
years and years and years in fact way
back in like kindy year one you first
met the first inverse functions that you
had to work with we just didn't call
them inverse functions they were
addition and subtraction addition and
subtraction of things you can do very
quickly without learning any fancy
language or that before you even know
what a function is let alone an inverse
function but they are your first example
of things that are well what is inverse
mean it comes from the word invert if
you think about turning something upside
down or turning it inside out reverse is
another similar thing you're changing
the direction of something so that's
exactly opposite to what it was before
and that's what addition and subtraction
ah yeah does that make sense
now I know in my and I'm sure mrs. Lee's
can confirm this in my conversations
with some of you if we've been talking
about how you've been going extension
one how you've got been going in
mathematics course I've made a point to
say hey look some topics are extension
one topics and some are not and so you
can sort of not freak out too much if
you know that mathematics is where
you're going to be placing most of your
effort this one's a bit funny it's an
extension one topic so you put this
asterisk key but it's one of those
extension one topics that is why you
will do so well in mathematics because
we've been working with inverse
functions for so long inverse functions
are in the tune of course we just don't
ever deal with them in any kind of
rigorous detail so the time and effort
that you spend at the understanding you
develop in this topic will requite for
you to do everything else much better
and with much more precision okay so let
me make that first note that this is an
extension one topic
so you will never see the word inverse
appear in an assessment task for
mathematics for to unit but you'll still
see the ideas like well you know and
your time you and subtracting you're
using these things and there are plenty
more and we're going to have a look at
some of them later okay
so that's the first point I wanted to
make the second point I want to make is
where we're going I told you where we've
come from the fact that we've been using
these for a long time but why are we
actually introducing this as a separate
oh here's a whole new special thing the
reason why is we want to solve a very
simple question which kind of been
begging its way into you which is that
we can differentiate lots of different
things now just rattle some things off
for me what the first things we learn to
differentiate what family of functions
where they start with the P polynomial
is very good we started with them you
know x squared X cube minus 1 yada yada
yada we learnt the rules to do with that
and we learn a product or chain rule
with polynomials and then we said ok you
know about lots of other functions what
other things can you differentiate now
you can do Exponential's along with
experiencers you can do logs which by
the way another pair of inverse
functions will come to the begin later
you know more than Exponential's logs
what's on this recent kind of thing you
learn to differentiate trigonometric
functions right so you know the
different riveters of sine and cos and
tan and all the different versions of
those there's one left there's one left
one family of functions that you've
worked with but you don't know how to
differentiate them yet and that's as you
can see a pattern right that's these
guys sine inverse cos inverse tan
inverse we know how to work with them
we've used them since you nine when you
were trying to find out the angle in a
right angle triangle and that kind of
thing but we don't know how to do
calculus with them and this is one of
the most surprising results in the
entire course but to understand why it
is what it is I mean if you wanted you
could just look at the reference sheet
right now and you can see the the result
that you especially get out because I
know okay but we're not just about
getting results and then just you know
popping them into a formula we actually
want to understand why on earth it is
what it is so that's where we're going
and we have some groundwork to lay ok so
underneath this I'd like you to draw for
me a bit of a table it's just to help us
wrap our head around
we've been dealing with these inverses a
lot before the tables going to have let
me have a look how many columns and rows
were here to have let's go three columns
if you if you've got columns already set
up in your page you're gonna be in some
trouble you're going to need before
width of the page but I'm I'm going to
use about this much and here we're going
to have three things we want to think
about functions that we know they're
inverse functions that we know about and
then that third column is just so we can
draw some pictures I'll come all that
grass okay so I've already clued you in
to our two different kinds of functions
that have inverses and one is on the
board so addition it's subtraction right
now these are operations not functions
so how can we talk about a function that
uses addition and the user subtraction
well let's just try a simple example
these are all just examples if I had a
function like f of X equals x plus 2
what weight inverse be what would be
something that takes that and turns it
upside down reverses its direction well
instead of adding two I'm going to
subtract two yeah start nice and gentle
over on the right hand side here let's
just draw a really small Cartesian plane
like so what do each of these functions
look like well I know an X plus two
looks like it's gonna be a straight line
gradient one and I'm going to shift it
vertically upwards two units so there
you go that's what he looks like
there's f of X there what does X minus 2
looks like well it's going to be very
similar but it's shifted down now I'm
going to introduce some notations to you
here and it's again it introduced ice
notation you've seen and used before but
you have to be really careful with it
when we talk about a function f of X we
label its inverse as f I'm gonna read
this out really carefully with the
negative 1 up there
as if it were the power of X now I say
as if it were the power it is not the
power write this and make a big sign for
this with a different color if you've
got it is not usually anyway going to be
equal to what we normally think of when
you put a negative one in the power what
do we normally think of we think about
the reciprocal 1 over right so it's
tempting to think this right but like I
said we've been using this negative one
notation before it's quite popular right
and we know that this is definitely not
sine inverse of X is definitely not one
on sine X we have a different name for
that what is that thing that's Cosette
different based altogether ok so the way
I actually read this rather than saying
negative one I say F inverse of X that's
the way I read it just to avoid the
confusion with using the negative one
side okay right so that's right nice
easy it function and it's inverse let's
do another one what is the other pair of
functions that I mentioned before that
are inverses of each other we're talking
about logs and Exponential's ok so it
doesn't matter which way you look
because as you can see this inverse I
could put over here and just swap them
around okay let's put the exponential
over here e to the X ok what would be
the inverse function of e to the X well
it's going to be a log what will its
base be well its base has to be the same
as this base if we want them to be
opposites of each other so log base e of
x again
show yourself a little Cartesian plane
one of these things going to look like
I'll give you a second to catch up and
draw while I make myself some space
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay you have some pictures there you've
got a to the extra know exactly what
this looks like it's going to be this
guy
I'll PR you don't have to worry too much
about drawing the asymptotes because
this is a small thing what does the log
function look like
well yeah it's hugging the y-axis like
so and then it goes off like that okay
so we're going to have f of X over here
and f inverse of X they're happy so far
okay now I want you to think for a
moment and I'm not going to I'm not
gonna lead you yet I can tell you
there's at least two really easy
accessible kinds of functions that you
know the inverse is off right there was
one on the board a second ago that I
just rubbed off this an even easier one
it's very closely related to this so I
want you to put two more rows onto your
table and I want you to think okay well
what's a function that I know about and
its inverse and what would they look
like
if I drew them I'll give you a clue
these are really basic operations right
they're not the only basic operations
you know about which you haven't
equivalent inverse for okay and then
keep on thinking I'll give you a minute
or two you can work with the people
around you as well and once you've come
up with something called me over and
I'll see if you're on the right track